[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu sein israels
heute gibt's einen wunsch rezept von
moral und war damit eine braune torte
gewünscht hier mit einer leckeren schoko
creme und einem schokokuss und seinen
lieblings früchten nämlich zu faul ist
ich hab das ganze noch ergänzt mit
granatäpfeln und blau blau
ja also gesund und früchte auf einem
wahrscheinlichen ungesund und controller
einfach her ich habe fürs und zucker
aber macht nichts schmeckt sehr lecker
und dann habe ich den traum zeigt
darüber eine schokoladencreme und den
fokus und das ganze ist auch wirklich
gar nicht schwierig er hat doch gesehen
oder ihr seht auch dass ich hier die
creme zum beispiel gar nicht so platt
gestritten habe das heißt haube statt an
macht den kuchen episode so gut aus wir
legen jetzt gleich los und ich zeige
euch mal die zutaten für den teig für
den politik brauche ich 150 gramm herrn
schokolade die habe ich bereits
geschmolzen 3 125 g zucker eine prise
salz etwas vanille extrakt 40 kamel
einen teelöffel backpulver 50 gramm
gemahlene mandeln und 100 gramm
ich nehme davon kein öl und ich messe
ganz gerne in gramm auch weil ich so
einfach alle tassen und teller auf die
waage stellen kann und ich kann sie nur
noch einführen kann in 100 gramm oder
100 milliliter unterschiedlich der blick
geht ganz einfach das ist kein
klassischer pro miettag sondern eine
braune torte
das heißt er wird jetzt nicht zuerst
flach und macht sagt widmann den schon
ein bisschen locker durch das aktive
aber soll er auch sein denn er war ja
richtig leckere torte machen habe ich
jetzt die eier schon mal in einer
schrift dann den drucker
dieses soll und wird ganz früher ist es
aber erstmal mit dem schnee wesentlich
einfacher etwa eine freundin
[Musik]
wenn die masse für den baum ist gebe ich
noch die geschmolzene schokolade mit
auto und ich nehme gerne herren
schokolade weil sie 60 prozent
kakaoanteil hat und hat soeben den
kompletten schock
[Musik]
das öl kommt jetzt auch mit atom und die
flut haben beiden kurz bei niedriger
stufe eingeführt
derzeit kann ich hier schon mal die
trockenen zutaten miteinander vermischen
und dann kommen die auch vom teig dafür
und weil der freiheit für mich flüssig
ist und auch in schneebesen weiter
benutzen falls ihr einen selbst klappt
müsste natürlich von uns nach höherer
benutzen
aber der schnee wir sind wirklich nur
flüssige sachen biete was für ein genie
und auch fahrer schlagen darf der teig
redete mit vorbereiteten batterien
gefüllten habe ich auf 18 cm ein
geschäft und da kommt jetzt betreiben
wird schön glatt gestrichen
ich bin immer gerne am rand etwas
entlang
so kann etwas gleichmäßiger aufgehen
[Musik]
und so mit der peitsche von vorhalten
backofen bei 160 grad ober unterhitze
etwa 35 minuten gebacken die am rand
bleibt dem anders aus als es kann mal
passiert aber das ist völlig ok der
frauen ist abwickeln
das werde ich die schokocreme zu
bereiten für die schokocreme habe ich
hier die zutaten für die
schokoladencreme auch 100 gramm
schokolade tier euch bereits geschmolzen
200 gramm schlagbar 200 gramm schmand
oder bauern zb 4 10 rabatt und wer
möchte noch ein paar flocken
wie könnt ihr natürlich nachgedacht so
geben wenn ihr das gerne möchte ich
denke von mit kleine briefe ist ganz
lecker denn ich mag auch seine ziele
schokolade und die cenit flocken habe
ich bereits in der mit fein gemahlen
jetzt gehe ich die kalte schlagsahne in
einer schüssel
dies sollte auch sehr kalt sein dann
kann ich schon ein bisschen berühren und
währenddessen die schokolade das vom
fliegen ab und geht jetzt nicht mehr
heiß auch nicht mehr waren schon gut
abgekühlt aber ebenso doch noch für sich
dagegen langsamer fahrt mit und kurz
bevor der steige gebe ich noch der
schwanz mit dazu
die viele zukünftig auch weil ich
einfach die schokolade in die kalte
sahne gegossen haben vermutlich fett
geworden ist gar nicht schlimm und wenn
wir das aber doch nicht möchte dann
müsst ihr die sahne aufkochen
die schokolade darin schmelzen und dann
müssen wir ganz klar erklären warum
halten lag vorstopper teller krämer vom
der schwanz mit akku und wenn ihr
möchtet gerne auch eine kleine messe
berlin
zwar gibt es erstmals drei ernsthafte da
könnt ihr gerne erstmals befreien dass
ich zwei perioden von egal murat es
schon haben später phobien und wenn ihr
möchtet nach ich mag einfach ein
bisschen mehr
die creme wir das noch schnell glatt
gerührt und schreibt geschlagen und dann
kommt sie auf die torte wenn diese noch
nicht fest genug geht er noch wirksamer
partner dazu und von mir fehlt auch noch
ein bisschen mehr filme und dann einfach
probieren
ich war verblüfft schärfer
dann muss halt erinnert ist nicht gut
die schiffe kommt immer erst danach
nehme ich den braune boden und ziehen
von der platte runter geht am besten mit
einem tornado und den lösung mit einem
backformen messer vom tortenring damit
die torte mit noch richtig gut werden
nämlich hier noch einen espresso und
weil die torte mit tränken aber doch
recht etwas schlecht davon auch
innovative extrakt der in keinem auch
keine lösung
ganz schön verführt und dann damit
kranken damit auch nicht den kompletten
körper nur die hälfte
die anderen nämlich aber das ist
wirklich nur optional um noch
kaffeegeschmack mit reinzubringen
ihr könnt auch weglassen denn da brown
sowieso schon dass ich genug
und da gebe ich jetzt die leckere creme
[Musik]
da blieb nur die oberfläche geglättet
den ramblas ich jetzt einfach sind ganz
schöne fündig wurden die logistikhalle
ausgeht und die torte steht für eine
halbe stunde in den kühlschrank und kann
in der zeit schon mal den schokokuss
machen die tafel sitzt bringt gekühlt
und jetzt kann ich schon mal die
dekoration verbreiten ich werde einen
schokokuss aufgeben und ein bisschen ob
du bist hier einen richtig schönen
granatapfel heidelbeeren und blaubeeren
und hier habe ich noch viele geben
granatapfel eine clique und den boden
lag und zeigt euch mal auf verschiedene
möglichkeiten um die kerne
rauszubekommen
entweder nimmt ihr die unterwäsche
methode das heißt wir nehmen und
schälchen mit wasser und könnte darin
öffnen
denn granatapfel spritzt ihr immer ganz
gerne
und so kann man das ganze ohne viel
dreck wegmachen herausnehmen oder in ihm
so einfach nur schüssel eine schöpfkelle
zum beispiel und können jetzt einfach
drauf haut spritzen natürlich ein
bisschen
[Musik]
soll steigen
die frühstück vorbereitet jetzt geht
weiter mit dem shop burg da nehme ich
jetzt die sahne und was sie kurz
aufkochen lassen und da kann gibt auch
schon mal das kokosöl meter zu geben
es gibt dem guss vorläufig schönen glanz
[Musik]
und sobald die sahne koch kann ich die
sahne vom herz herunterziehen abschnitt
den herd ausgemacht
und da kommt die kuvertüre mit rein und
wird durch geburt wichtig die kuvertüre
komplett aufgelöst hat
[Musik]
dieses kirche in dem topf würde jetzt
einfach zu heiß bleiben
so kann er ganz kurz abkühlen ich habe
die torte auf einem drehteller wir
könnten gut besser darüber verteilen
jetzt geht nichts drüber und mit der
palette damit gleich das ganze besser
verteilen
[Musik]
mit dem schocker gut habe ich jetzt
übrig gelassen und jetzt nehme ich die
bären die granatäpfel und dies alles und
west schon bitten wir
[Musik]
murat das ist der moment um den sich
viele bereiten wieder schön heute aber
ein aufgefallen
aber schön also ich schneide mal richtig
freuen sich die schüler unter mitte hier
ist der brauch ich für richtig feucht
das wird ein geschmackvoll der über
geschmack lässt sich streiten
das bedeutet entweder man lässt sich
streiten schaut mal was wir hier stark
wodurch wo die fälligkeit angesprochen
hat wenn ich das nicht so gerne mag mit
dem feuchten ronny muss man einfach
länger backen
aber ich bin im blauen muss einfach
feucht und saftig sein deswegen darf er
in der methode aus steingut irgendwie
kriegen ist offen die creme ist auch
spannend sahne und herren schokolade
weiß noch was schwank aus österreich
weiß aber ihr könnt zum beispiel auch
laura nehmen und mit den früchten run
öffnet die knacken dann so die 20
weißware oben oder cremige
technologisches das heißt wenn du angst
hast du zu sicher sein und früchte drauf
und max ganz leicht im nachteil
ich habe ein halben teelöffel millimeter
ich bin nur ganz schwach im nachgang
wenn man das ganze team elastischer
machen möchte kann man natürlich ein
bisschen mehr dazu geben aber ich möchte
gar nicht krank
ja ich möchte dass zur führung lassen
vor dem spiel schon länger anspruch ist
krank man kann die twitter die auf
austausch kann vielleicht im nachhinein
manipuliert war kann die früchte
ausbauen
gerade hat abschluss macht mich das weiß
ich und feuer haben will der kann macht
den total gaben der betrieb zum beispiel
oder andere früchte zu rap website könnt
ihr auch etwas zum beispiel nehmen also
da passen wirklich alles doch sowas von
bisschen teurer haben oder mandarin
halte dieses rezept nach machen wollt
ihr könnt ihr gerne noch anschauen dann
schaut auch wenn ich mir das noch mal
ganz genau und ich wünsche euch jetzt
schon ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wird dann
klingt kühl was liebe einfach diese
herren schokolade wer schokolade total
im wohnpark mit 60 prozent kakaoanteil
anderen einfach bitter schokolade die
hat 50 oder 55 prozent
[Musik]
zitronen